so there's a lot to discuss uh this
season deals with the aftermath of
susannah's death obviously and um the
two people impacted most are your two
characters Conrad and Jeremiah the two
brothers
um process things really differently
right uh what do you think was going
through your character's head at the
time in the time following the death
because we don't get to see that much of
the like immediate after effect I I
think um
it's a something that is very confusing
for both of them
um and I think
that
something like that
leaves them maybe
just
lost a little bit
um and sort of grasping onto something
that feels real and tangible and
um
you know palpable I think they're just
sort of grasping for things yeah and but
in in their individual ways because they
are different people
um
but they're desperate I think whether
they know it or not yeah yeah I think uh
Jeremiah I don't know if I can speak on
on Conrad but uh Jeremiah's kind of
alone during all of this he is alone
um and it makes that really apparent
throughout the season uh and you know
it's
I think being alone is a wonderful gift
but also like doing life and
experiencing hardship with Community is
always so much easier and so
um I think Jeremiah is really just going
through the thick of it with uh his mom
and everything
um doing it alone so and so last season
we got to see Conrad sort of in the
spotlight with belly so to speak uh but
this season focused a little bit more on
Jeremiah and his relationship with belly
Gavin what was your favorite part about
developing that relationship with Lola
and um working on bringing them closer
than we saw them yeah I mean
um I feel like with the script and the
seasons and all of all of that you know
it's kind of really led to their
relationship growing in a beautiful way
and so to really be able to put that on
a screen was was a lot of fun
um plus Lola's she's so talented and so
it was really easy it was really really
easy to work with her and and to do
those scenes because uh you know we just
we feel like the the scenes in this
season has been building up to it for so
long so yeah
and Chris I mean oh man Conrad he was
making some silly choices this season
these I like I like that he's the kind
of character who always like shoulders
burdens on his own I feel like that's an
interesting aspect of his character
um but do you ever have moments when you
just want to shake him and be like get
out of your own way uh how did you react
to his journey I mean this season with
belly with you know Brown and the you
know this drama with the house ownership
what was that what was that like for you
constantly I I want to shake him and
yell at him constantly
um but
it's funny because like
starting
to to to try and like learn about this
character was was hard in a lot of ways
because I was like man he's making all
these like the first season he was
making like all these bad decisions and
being mean to people and yeah and then
we come back for season two and I'm like
all right what's he gonna do now and
then he's like doing worse stuff and
being less considerate and
um less thoughtful but um
that's I don't know that's sort of what
I enjoy about it and enjoying about
playing him is he's young and he's
learning a lot and he's making mistakes
and he's
um
malleable you know I mean he's he's
I think nothing but
but honest I think he's very clear about
what he wants and um
how he wants to go about life and he
does it in the wrong way often but I
think that's kind of I think that's kind
of beautiful yeah I mean it's very it's
very his age like those decisions that
he makes I'm like yeah that's what I do
yeah
and I'm asking this question to
everybody and I kind of know what you
guys are going to answer I'm gonna guess
but who do you guys think uh you guys
personally not your characters things
should end up with belly I think it's
hard to say I think
that because like
like I I think that at the end of season
two belly and Jeremiah should be
together
um and I think that in the same way at
the end of season one I think Conrad and
belly should were meant to be together
because
both times at different points in their
lives it's what these two characters
want yeah
um and what their hearts desire
and who is anyone to tell them not to
yeah I think with the growth that all
the characters are experiencing
um for a heart to just kind of go back
and forth
um it just really shows like how much we
can change as human beings
um
um on a day-to-day basis basically
um but yeah I agree like I think you
know in the end of season one it just
made sense uh with Conrad and now I
think uh for season two there's you know
a little time for Jeremiah to shine
um but you know who knows
I mean I think you guys did a great job
I was very much in the same boat I
season one I was so strongly like yes it
works and then season two was like oh
okay I'm here for this as well so you
guys did a good job um thank you so much
for speaking with me I really really
enjoyed season two and I loved you know
getting to see all the character
Dynamics together and I can't wait to
see what you guys have in store for
season three so yeah thank thank you
thank you thank you so much appreciate
it so much yeah I appreciate your time